here's what would happen if you lost  your teeth overnight well first you  would notice it would be more difficult  to speak as many words and sounds  require that your tongue make contact  with your teeth for pronunciation  without teeth you wouldn't be able to  chew your gums and jaws would need to  work overtime to break up the food  enough for you to swallow it would be  nearly impossible to eat hard foods  without teeth your gums would be  completely exposed and highly prone to  bacterial infections like gingivitis and  periodontitis unless treated with  antibiotics and constant deep cleaning  you would suffer big time  another shocking thing that would happen  without teeth is that your jawbone would  weaken so be careful even the slightest  bump to your face could hurt a lot  you would need to switch to an all  liquid diet blending your fruits veggies  and proteins into smoothies or soups so